welcome to your mom's house
vbs2 this feature and here's that mom
and the the tattoo on the right hand see
the really big tattoo on the right hands
remember that from the white pride
worldwide t-shirts and then you wait
like one more minute into this PBS
profile and then we get her left hand
and what's on her left hand
oh what's on that's the eight eight hi I
love Rachel Maddow you love her don't
you Rachel
yeah I don't know you do I thought you
really liked Rachel no Suze Orman you
like Suze oh yeah these are girl yeah
the finance lady yeah I thought you
really liked Rachel too right
I mean I wouldn't I feel weird saying I
thought that I disliked right I just
never considered like hey you know I
really like ya I thought you had a thing
oh that's Christiana um yeah I like
Christiane Amanpour yeah
she's a journalist though you think her
her butthole I never really thought of
Miss I'm a poor that way I'm sorry that
my wife disrespected you with that
question I consider her a a fine
journalist yeah she's really good uh
rachel is really good at her job but
she's more like a you know news sort of
evolved or devolved into the the
business of entertainment and a fan yeah
so she's really great at what she does
but she's you know she's a mouthpiece
for the left which is fine I mean I
enjoy what she does she's no it's just
it's just what her job is
no job is that and obviously her job is
to listen to podcasts well which is
clearly she's biting you know from the
show yeah
she's and I and I look in that respect I
respect that she's doing it oh she's a
Danny out first her hardcore day yeah
she deviant or your mom's house fan I'm
not sure oh that's interesting yeah I
mean it could be it could be either one
I guess I never so great that this woman
has total white pride
yeah what state is this in that that's
totally acceptable to go to or quit
doing them the Yates and the Cisco what
are the eight signified by the way I
didn't really know that I just know okay
the eighth letter in the alphabet is age
is that c d e f g h so hitler eight
eight yeah AG well you just you know the
thing I don't think she realizes is that
he is not gonna respond to tattoos
Hitler's straight watches he likes blogs
you got a record a video and you talk to
him that way if you if you do a tattoo
or what he totally misses that's well
because in Argentina his Wi-Fi
connections really really good yeah but
he's still underground so he can only
he's got watch he got a funnel through
all these things but if you want to get
looks got a busy day yeah busy busy
just like Winston Churchill he lays in
bed he does most of us right from bed my
man's got shit to do yeah so log things
he's got a lot of logs dancer there's a
way to get in touch with them and right
now you're kind of amazing I'm a huge
raging metal fan I know Rachel thank you
for noticing one of my disciples